you've probably heard of cloud identity
and access management IAM but what can
you do with it IAM is a service that
helps manage access to Google Cloud
resources at a granular level put simply
it helps you control who can access your
resources and what they can do with them
you can think of it as the bouncer at
the cloud Club it ensures that only
authorized Personnel have access to
sensitive information that's inside the
club this helps prevent data breaches
and unauthorized changes to resources
plus it helps ensure compliance with
regulatory requirements such as HIPAA or
PCI DSS if you're a Hands-On learner
like me then you'll enjoy this
interactive tutorial that takes you
through how to Grant IAM roles make sure
the access works and how to revoke roles
check out the pinned comment for a
desktop link to the tutorial because